galinari gives to young
the floater oh my goodness
we got overtime trey young
misses the floater now this is a
great call out i mean this is trey's
shot
it is and we thought man i i can't
believe that didn't go
i didn't need a 12 foot rebound capella
oh he had a battle for that one
buck donovan oh he had the three
young fires and he drains it the basket
instead of stopping and popping
and he used his body in the rim to
protect his shot 32 for tamar
young great fake and hits another one
it's just very patient there took his
time
and he got the match-up that he wanted
and another floater from trae young
burst by
one
[Applause]
young again doesn't miss this one
then usually a lot more patient than
that right trey
hits a three cold blooded
absolutely and hawks have wanted it in
his truck and trey here
and rudy gate what are you doing you got
to close out a little closer
and trey said no no no if you're going
to stay there i'm going to make you pay
for
not coming out here see rudy's so you
sneak
of trey getting in the lane and shooting
that flow
has been forced out of the comfort zone
the hawks defense has been really good
trey gets to the glasses
that's just what rudy was afraid of if i
come out on him
he's going to go by me that's why they
call a help defense stinger
your teammates got to help yes they do
trey young
look at the read bob won't get the read
just
on a blow-by yeah he really had no
chance no
last time i tried to show i stayed here
that he's used to jump i go out he goes
by me what do you want me to do
pops we're units to foul here
trey coming down the sideline gallow
corner three good oh count all of those
galileari with the fake of the night
double dig
he faked the pass back to the middle of
the florida defense man
all bottom jump shooter in the house
can i get that again jill let me get
another look at that one please
stinger likes to jump shooters oh my
goodness i live for jump shots
take a look at this right here give that
fake gallo oh
come here you know the thing is is why
mary why are you jumping in the air
on an attempted pass you got to stay
down